basili polonsky trabajó durante seis
años en el canal de televisión web
independiente 2 hoy empuja en la puerta
de un estudio del que sólo quedan ruinas
móvil y calendario interno tedax a esta
era nuestra sala de prensa de internet
que me gustaba mucho aquí está la fila
de estaciones de edición de vídeos a tu
juego
y aquí frente a este puesto estaba
administración de trabajo esto el 3 de
marzo vasili presentó en directo el
programa de despedida de la cadena
después casi toda la redacción abandonó
rusia una hemorragia ya que la censura
de guerra se impone personal sobre
este es nuestro momento el momento de
las noticias calientes cuando ocurren
los eventos a cubrir deberíamos estar
trabajando como nunca y en cambio esto
es todo
vasili publica ahora sus informes en
youtube amenazado de cierre después de
dos trabajo durante una semana en el
periódico independiente nóvaya gazeta
que también fue cerrado un caso como el
de green habló jean que llevaba 16 años
trabajando para la emisora de radio eco
de moscú y terminó cerrada el periodismo
ya no existe nuestra profesión ya no
existe que será de los graduados de las
facultades de periodismo no lo sé al
igual que basile irina se ha convertido
en blogger a su último texto una
investigación sobre la propaganda de los
medios de comunicación estatales
hemos recibido un memorándum interno que
indica los medios de comunicación del
grupo news media como deben tratar
distintos temas empezar diciendo que
ucrania quiere la guerra y bombardea su
propia población y terminar diciendo que
todo es culpa de occidente
si intentas desviarte de estas notas
internas y no seguir la línea oficial de
información que te imponen te arriesgas
a 15 años de cárcel a jake y mientras
están informados
te conviertes en un enemigo al igual que
basile irina es una de las últimas
periodistas independientes que trabajan
en rusia y como él sabe lo que arriesga